i've admired you over the years i really
have
not just as a comedian but as someone
who i consider to be a
spiritual wanderer and adventurer
i mean that i'm not talking religiously
i mean
i'm talking about the fact that you you
seem to care about people and connecting
with them
i love connecting with people i like
well you know there are comics that
don't like people in their comics that
do like people i
i'm a loner in my life but i do like
people
and i'm interested in i know this sounds
hippie dippy granola or whatever but
energy like it's i feel like that's i
don't feel i know it's real like the
energy what do they say like it cannot
be uh
created nor destroyed energy cannot be
created or destroyed that's true
yeah so like but it can convert so you
know like someone gives you
the finger on the freeway it like
gives you bad energy and you pass that
on and it's catchy but like
good energy too can be catchy this is my
point but i
believe in this because i think growing
up in the 70s and 80s
i picked up bad energy and i've just
been passing it on ever since
yeah which is fun by the way i think
it's hilarious i read that about you on
your wikipedia page
it's it's the first six paragraphs of my
wikipedia page
i uh i believe that though you get that
energy you give bad energy
you seem to be yeah you don't believe in
the mind-body connection how do you
explain nervous diarrhea
that's the question that many people
have pondered and
you've cracked it you can't yeah exactly
i mean that's what a great statement
i've seen this in life you describe
yourself as someone who likes people
i've noticed that there's some comedians
who are not themselves when they're with
other people
they're they're you see their persona on
stage and then you see who they are
backstage you're always yourself
and you seem like you're a positive
person like you're trying to convert
everyone's energy to good energy is that
true
i try to i when i'm conscious of it i
mean obviously i can
i'm sure i can be a dick you know but
like ora
would i don't mean to make it a male
body part but you know what i mean
right an [ __ ] yeah um yeah
but uh i was at going to the weed store
actually right around the corner from
here and i pull in
and i you know parallel parking is hard
for anyone
and then i i go up
i go up a little and then i back up and
the guy in front of me was in his car i
i
i didn't even really kiss it i didn't
touch his car i really didn't but
he must have been in a really bad place
who knows what was going on in his life
he was this big guy in a big suv he gets
out of his car and starts screaming
at me and he's like you hit my car
and you know i and i uh
i i didn't hit it but i just went sorry
you know that's
i go i'm sorry because oh you're sorry
you're sorry i guess that makes it all
better then right
and i can't even do anything about it
because you're a girl you know like
which was like were you gonna
punch someone and um
i and so i i i took a second i go
my heart was pounding but i go here's my
chance to try to like convert energy
so i work up my you know guts and
everything
and i uh get out of the car and i go up
to him and i go
i i'm going to make this right show me
where the scratch is i'm going to fix it
let me pay for it
no forget it i go no i want to make this
right but you know there was no scratch
there but
he's like just it's fine and i go
i'm gonna buy you weed and then he
laughed a little i go
he goes no you don't have to i go what
what kind do you like
he had like a russian or ukrainian
accent but i'm not good at accents
yeah he goes uh i like the kind that
gives you a full body high
indica indica it is
so then i go into the weed store and i'm
waiting in line
and as i'm waiting in line i see the uh
meter person what do you say for meter
maid now
well uh me to say meter reader meter
reader there you go meter reader
a meter reader but my car is kind of out
of view but i see the meteor i go oh
with all this
commotion i didn't put money in my thing
uh
so then the uh bouncer come there's like
a security guy at weed stores
and he comes in and i go i know i got a
ticket he goes no
your new friend over there put uh money
in the meter for you
that's fantastic so i i get the pot and
i come out i give it to him and i go
i heard you're my hero he goes then he's
all fashionable oh it's
nothing you know and then uh he shakes
my hand and i hadn't shaken anyone this
was a
few months ago i hadn't shaken anyone's
hand but i go oh screw it i'm going to
shake his hand i'll just puree out later
we shake hands i go look at us we were
arch enemies and now we're best friends
and he was laughing
and then as i pulled out he like took it
upon himself to like
guide traffic you know that's so sweet
but see
see this is the thing most people in
that situation if someone's yelling at
you in a car
they yell back and it escalates you know
you did the thing that no one does which
is you say how can i make this right
i'm going to buy you weed if we all went
around offering each other weed
things would be so much better in this
world i agree
yeah that's all we ever needed